[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists and we are here
it's an exciting day we're here with our
brand new co-host his name
is tk coleman ladies and gentlemen tk
coleman
i was literally born yesterday
brand new
[Laughter]
so ryan we were talking earlier on the
private podcast and we realized this is
like steph and clay finally being joined
hmm by matt mcclung
i was hoping you would say matt mcclong
not kd because matt mcclong is the next
scott skyles dude no one's gonna get
that reference hey but that's a bad dude
man that dude can play
blah so we do have tk is our new kd
though let's be honest here we've won
some championships before him but now
he's on the team we're we're taking the
podcast to a whole new level a whole new
format preach and
i cannot wait tk why are we doing this
because you need me to handle lebron
that's right because when we get in the
clutch and you're like
hey somebody needs to go get a bucket
you know you can give me the ball and
i'll
take it to the hole
i need a talking language that people
will actually understand we're doing
this man because it's fun sometimes we
fail to listen to our hearts and do what
we are called to do because we felt like
we need to have this really profound
philosophical sophisticated
justificatory answer for everything we
do the reality is in the absence of a
logically and morally compelling reason
to do otherwise you should do what you
love
you should do what's fun what feels
right for you and this feels right so i
can pretend like it's about you know the
analysis of this pro and the analysis of
that con but that would just be me
conning you with a story that i think
you would respect me for having i'm
doing this because it feels like a hell
yes amen what's the hell yes for all of
us
did you think when you were on our
podcast for the very first time were you
like one day
i'm gonna be the third host on this show
no i had no concept of that whatsoever
but
for the first time i'm like we need to
get tk on here more
was it like love at first oh yeah
absolutely you're like he's the one for
me yeah right oh dude i didn't know that
man it feels so good my first time i
felt like
my first time on this show
i've i felt like
you got to be clear these days man
because people will eat you alive in the
youtube comments you were thinking about
josh your first time
my first time on this show i thought man
this feels so great you know what i mean
like this
of all the interviews and conversations
i've done i feel like the chemistry and
the camaraderie
is better here than it's ever been and
just the balance between levity and
gravity the willingness to get serious
but the unapologetic willingness to
laugh at the same time
so good man yeah so good thanks i'm
ready man i'm excited coming up today on
this free public minimal episode we're
talking to a listener about having a
funeral for things we'll also have a
outstanding lightning round question for
you you can check out the full
three hour maximal episode this week
where we answer four times the questions
and we dive deep into seven new simple
living segments that private podcast
episode is out right now at
theminimalists.com
private or just click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free
our first question today is from stephen
in fort worth texas
a good work buddy of mine recently
passed away without any warning he
seemed healthy one day the next day he
was on the ground at work having a
seizure
and a week later he was gone
shortly after he died they had a funeral
and invited all of us from work
i was still in shock and i just couldn't
pull myself to go
i didn't want to see him dead like that
i guess i wasn't ready for the closure
they say a funeral brings
now i'm feeling a bunch of guilt for not
going to his final send-off and giving
my condolences to his family letting
them know we all love the dude so much
i know you guys always say don't do
things because society tells us to
but is going to a friend or family
member's funeral the ultimate social
pressure
something we're expected to do and if we
don't
we're being very disrespectful to that
person or their family now tk i wanted
to start with this question because you
and i had a phone call recently and we
were talking about different kinds of
funerals and what i realized from that
conversation is that a funeral
is sort of a celebration of letting go
and here's what i mean by that i moved
out of the apartment condo that i'd been
renting for the last five years that was
in west hollywood
and my family moved up to ventura county
and in doing that
all of these emotions began to stir up
within me because i realized i was
moving on to something and in order to
move on i had to let go
of what had served me for a period of
time now we're not talking about a
person here we're talking about a thing
or a place right and in this case it was
both
and all of the sentimentality that gets
tied up into a place or into a thing and
sometimes it makes sense to have a
funeral so i literally when i moved out
the day i moved out i had a funeral
for that chapter of my life i was
celebrating it
in order for me to let go i was
appreciating it for what it was and i
find that we can do that for things as
well as we start to let go of material
possessions
we can say hey thank you this is
something marie kondo does ethan thanks
the thing for serving a purpose but it's
no longer serving a purpose so i am
going to let it go i'm going to sell it
donate it
recycle it trash it if i have to
in order to let go but just because you
let go of the thing doesn't mean you've
let go of the thing
because what happens sometimes is i let
go of the physical thing but then i
cling to it in my mind and that's quite
often what we do with relationships if
someone dies i remember when my mother
died obviously that was a traumatic
experience for me and because she was
gone
it was physically i had to physically
let go
but mentally emotionally it took a while
for me to let go
and
realizing this many years later is that
the celebration or the funeral isn't for
the person who died the funeral
is for the people who need to let go of
that person and when i talked to you on
the phone recently you were at a funeral
and we started talking about having
funerals for people for things for
places so that we can move on
that's right so the the man who passed
away in my life was my father's
right-hand man
and although my my childhood was filled
with many great men
this particular guy his name was lorenzo
was the guy that was always there
whenever my father couldn't be
and um
[Music]
he because he was always there it was
important to me
in closing out that chapter of my life
to be there for him at that moment and i
said at his funeral the reason i came as
inconvenience as inconvenient and costly
as it was is because i knew for sure if
it was my funeral he would have been
there and so by being there for him in
that moment it gave me the opportunity
to sort of close it out and say here's
what he represented to me and here's how
i can let his legacy uh live through me
but you're absolutely right you know um
death is a kind of letting go and it's
easier to let go when you take the time
to consider who this person was or what
this thing was and you
you evaluate what it meant to your life
and how it shaped your story that makes
it easier to let go and i think it's
interesting that this question is coming
from someone who says i'm having trouble
letting go
i'm also the guy that didn't go
there's kind of a correlation there
right
that's why we go not because we're
morally obligated to do so but because
we go for us now to address this
question directly though
very quickly there's this parable that
jesus tells
where a guy has two sons and the father
he asked both sons to do work for him
one son says no i'm not going to do it.
the other son says yes i'll do it the
son who said yes
forgets and never gets around to it the
son who says no
has a change of heart later on and he
goes and gets the work done and the
question that jesus asks is
who was the good son
was it the one who said the right things
or was it the one who did the right
thing and the answer was it was the one
who did the right thing even though what
he said
didn't quite match that and
i think it's interesting because we can
live our entire lives
hating people
ignoring them
not being a good friend to them but then
we show up to their funeral and we say
all the right things
and then we can spend our entire lives
loving people enjoying their company
and then we miss the funeral
because of some kind of unforeseen
circumstance and we feel terrible as if
we fail them and what i would say to you
stephen is i would care more about how i
treated that friend when he was alive
than i would about my inability or my
failure to go to the funeral because the
best way to honor someone's legacy is
not to show up at a funeral service and
say things that aren't a match to what
you actually did but it's to treat them
with respect and kindness and love when
they're here and then to allow that same
respect kindness and love to live
through you you represent the highest
values that they exhibit it to you and
then you embody that in your
interactions with others i would let go
of the guilt because either your friend
is unconscious of you right now or he's
conscious of you if he's unconscious of
you then he's not holding it against you
and if he's conscious of you he's
probably got higher dimensional things
to be worried about than that and he's
probably wishing that you would forgive
yourself and let that go honor him not
by going to the event that's already
passed you can't control that honor him
by taking a moment and saying what did
he mean to me what were those qualities
i loved about him and how can i give him
a head nod and pay homage to him by
treating other people in that way yeah
it's
melbourne that was such a fascinating
perspective on funerals it's not for the
person who died
it is for the people who show up there
so uh stephen it sounds to me he's
having trouble letting go of this guilt
because uh he wasn't like he said he
wasn't ready to let go he didn't get an
opportunity to tell this this man's
family
what an important person he was
so i mean stephen if that's it i mean i
don't think there's anything wrong with
like uh making a phone call maybe
sending a letter or maybe saying sending
an email
and just tell them exactly what you just
told us hey i really wish i could have
managed to the funeral i wasn't ready to
let go
but um you know i'm ready to let go now
but i just want to let you all know how
important this man was at our work
um yeah this made me think of stan when
we got like all that sudden news from we
had a friend who passed away january
2014
we were um just starting our 100 city
tour and it was out of the blue and he
it's interesting because like he told me
that he had a history of heart problems
and that he needed to look out for his
health but he looked like a pretty
healthy guy um but he passed away from a
heart attack and like josh and i got
that news i don't even think we had our
first stop yet we were in we were in
tampa just our saint pete just like yeah
staying in a hotel we haven't even had
our first stop yet
and my first inclination was let's go
let's go to the funeral let's go to the
funeral and
and we were looking at it and it just it
wasn't gonna work like it would it just
wasn't gonna work and
um i didn't feel guilty about it i
certainly had a longing to be there and
like again to support um to support his
family and to let his family know but it
was funny i um i was talking to a friend
who did go to the funeral
and he went up to stan's father
said hey i just want to let you know
that uh josh melbourne and ryan
nicodemus they really send their
condolences and they're sorry they
couldn't be here and
stance that was like
nicodemus nicodemus nicodemus
[Laughter]
because because it says it all yeah and
but i mean all that to say is is that
you know uh uh stan's dad knew i never
met stan's dad but stan knew me or i'm
sorry stan's dad knew me through stan
because um he knew that you know we were
close friends so um yeah it's okay you
didn't go to the funeral let that go
this guilt i think is something maybe
you want to look at in the future
stephen like guilt is a symptom of
something that you've done wrong i
wouldn't feel shame around it but this
guilt you can use as leverage uh to make
a different decision if you should have
you know a decision similar to this in
the future and i would say also that is
true and even doubly true
for deaths that aren't
people deaths that aren't human death
but the death of a thing if something
stops adding value to my life it has
died in an important way
although we continue to hold on to those
carcasses that's why i call the
container store i don't call them
storage containers i call them clutter
coffins because that's quite often what
we do we take our dead things the things
that are no longer serving us
and we put them in these coffins and
then we create these mausoleums
basements addicts etc where we store
these dead things well why because we
never stopped to have that funeral for
them and the way that you and i had a
funeral for stan
wasn't to go to his actual funeral but
there's an essay in our book essential
which by the way stephen i'd love to
send you a copy of that book the last
essay in that book is called live like
stan
and wow and what we talk about in there
is he died when he was 36 but he lived
more than most 86 year olds and i think
that's something that's worth noting the
health span of a person is not the same
thing as the lifespan of a person and so
yes maybe he didn't have the longest
life but he had a life in which he
actually
lived and so stephen
what is going to help you live here well
it's clear that letting go
is going to help you live so if you
enjoy our podcast we'd love to send you
an audiobook version of essential i
think it's our longest audiobook it's
like six or seven hours or if you want
the book book or the ebook version we'll
be happy to send those to you as well
stephen ryan what time is it you know
what time it is it's time for the
lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions your comments and anything
else you want to send us you can text it
to
four six 937-202-4650 four yes indeed
now during the lightning round the story
do our best to answer questions with a
short shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text to these
minimal maxims and the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media by the way thanks to our
good friend social jess you can find all
of our minimal maxims over at
minimalmaxims.com
looks like mike has a question for us
i'm bothered by my mother moving on to
be with another man less than a year
after my father's death i'm trying to be
supportive but i'm struggling to accept
this guy parking in my dad's spot on the
driveway any advice um so
this is fascinating ryan yeah it is
because i was talking about this a few
episodes ago i think it was episode
348 so here's my pithy answer for you
maybe we can unpack it together nobody
has the power to bother you
unless you hand them that power
and by the way i do this all the time so
this is not a judgment it is merely an
observation anytime that i am bothered
it's because i've given you that power
to bother me here's the irony of this
and i haven't talked to you about it yet
although there's an email sitting in
your inbox right now
um we
we had dr susan david on the podcast and
it was a wonderful episode especially
that maximal episode that we did with
her
and
my goodness it was it was a beautiful
conversation i felt like we had right
and one of the best moments was this
moment where i started talking about how
no one has the power to upset you unless
you hand them that power and then i went
on to talk about my own expectations
creating a prison around me
and she had a great line where she
talked about expectations and then we
shared that clip on
tick tock and instagram just a short
little one minute clip of us having that
dialogue and susan's people reach out to
us afterwards and they were like hey uh
can you please take that clip down oh
wow
and she's like we don't think this
represents
susan's point of view
i said well yeah
it probably doesn't
i didn't post it to represent her point
of view when tk says something on the
podcast it doesn't represent my point of
view right ryan says something on the
podcast it doesn't represent my point of
view now i'm not going to be silenced
here's here's the irony of this when i
got that email what i was upset yeah
right and so
i was upset how ironic yes right because
i gave that power to them to upset me
and
it's really hard to to understand that
any time that i get angry any time i get
frustrated any time i get sad because of
what someone else has done to me
all i've done is hand them that power to
manipulate my emotions and the same is
also true with happiness ryan you don't
have the ability to make me upset you
also don't have the ability to make me
happy only i have the ability to make me
happy here's the quandary though that
happiness is already there that is my
default state happiness
and yet
i often cover it up why because i have
set an expectation or i've handed the
power of my emotions over to tk or
mallory or jordan or whomever
i've set expectations that make me
miserable it's not you who's making me
miserable it's the schopenhauer quote
a man does not enjoy paris he enjoys
himself
in paris
i always say about my wife i don't enjoy
beck so i enjoy myself in backs
[Laughter]
hey yo sex joke i'm gonna need a
confession booth like yeah right in the
corner of the studio oh for each episode
you know the happiness is the default
state uh i don't know if we can
i don't know if we can uh
you know go off on too much of a tangent
here but it's funny because i think
about
a child being born
and the default state is like discomfort
crying
needing
longing wanting constantly
literally screaming for attention
and it's not until you know they start
to like try and figure things out
that they start to really be happy and
they start to um
uh yeah like just have that joy that
that you see little kids have i didn't
say that it was the only state no no no
yeah yeah yeah right in fact we talked
about this my favorite episode we've
done two amazing episodes recently one
was with tk called political clutter
it's a private podcast episode and
another private podcast episode we did
it might be my favorite of all time it
was called how to be satisfied and it
was episode 349 and we dissected this
long article about how to want less by
arthur c brooks
and in that conversation
you and i determined that happiness or
satisfaction
is the default state and
dissatisfaction is also the default
state oh yeah we did talk about that
yeah it was
the only reason i bring this up is
because i think there is something
to recognize or to form like a
daytauntworth or a relationship with
discomfort when we're uncomfortable
we're that's where we're not happy right
and when that discomfort arises within
us
then um when we project that out like
that's when
we're not happy
but
understanding that
uh like getting comfortable with that
discomfort like holding space for that
discomfort allowing to be a little bit
uncomfortable will actually lead you to
this default state of happiness
yeah yeah
all right i gotta pick the answer for
this one um mike
when in doubt choose compassion when
when mike asked his question it reminded
me of when
uh my
parents split up
and my mom went and got a boyfriend and
my dad went and got a girlfriend and i
was furious
i was so jealous
i was like no these are my parents
you know um i don't have room for two
more parents
and uh i had like a real i acted like a
real jerk there was one girlfriend my
dad had that i know for a fact like she
broke up with him because like i was so
intolerable like i was just
i'm so sorry hope if you're listening to
this i'm so sorry for being such a jerky
little kid
but
but it makes me think though if i could
go back i wish i could hold compassion
for my mom i wish i could hold
compassion for my dad because that would
have helped me to at least
take the edge off of that jealousy or
that discomfort that i feel you know
another pithy answer is um compassion is
an an antidote
to suffering
and uh it sounds like there's some
suffering going on here and and mike if
there's any way you can find any
compassion for your mom because she's
going through a lot too
um
that might help at least help you see it
through her eyes rather than feeding
into this
this emotion of anger or jealousy or
whatever emotion you would call it
yeah ryan you're you're making me think
of something with ella ella's nine now
my daughter and bex and i went on a trip
to seattle recently had an awesome time
and we were talking to her on the the
phone after the fact she was with her
biological dad and
bex was like yeah we had such a great
time and you could see the look of
ella's face she said you you had fun
without me oh wow oh man and so she
presupposes that
she needs to be there in order for
bex to enjoy herself for me to enjoy
myself otherwise we can't have joy
and
all bex did was turn around she said hey
you've been gone for a few days you've
been doing the summer camp thing mm-hmm
have you had any fun without us
hell it goes oh yeah
now tk you had a really interesting
pithy answer that i made even pithier
here so if you want to read that and
maybe we can expand on it a little bit
yes sir
your heart can't afford the damage the
damage caused by judging and resisting
your heart can't afford the damage
caused by judging and resisting
one of the
phrases that jumped out at me about this
question is
you said less than a year
my mother moving on to be with another
man
less than a year after my father's death
and so there's a kind of
evaluation that's going on there
that
maybe my mother should have taken
more time before jumping into a new
relationship and there's an underlying
assumption beneath that judgment
something like
to move on quickly
is to move on flippantly
and c.s lewis calls this chronological
snobbery which is the idea of judging
the goodness or badness of something
based on how old it is how new it is how
fast it is how slow it is right because
there are fast things there are things
that move fast that are terrible things
that move slow that are good there are
things that are very old and terrible
things that are very new and good and
vice versa
one way we can kind of see how this is a
manifestation of that is look at the
opposite criticizing someone who takes a
long time to get over the death of a
loved one right someone's spouse or
significant other passes away it's two
years later and they're still sad
haven't you moved on yet
oh yeah haven't you moved on yet come on
it's already been two years and maybe
that's because we imagine ourselves in
that situation and we imagine that we
would have moved on by then and so we
project our own pacing onto them and say
you should be over it by now
well judging someone for moving on too
quickly is similar to judging them from
moving on too slowly one makes the
assumption that to move on quickly is to
move on poorly and the other is to move
on slowly i mean to move on uh quickly
is to move on flippantly
and so what i would say is
allow your mother the space
to move on in the way that is best for
her
and to know that this too is a part of
her healing process there is no
disrespect to your father in how much
time it takes her to move on to a new
relationship the other thing i would say
is that
her moving on too quickly
might be
less of an indicator of anything going
on with her and more of an indicator on
your own readiness to embrace this and
that's okay maybe it's too quickly for
your comfort level maybe it's really
hard for you to celebrate this
relationship when you're still letting
go and what i would encourage you to do
especially if you have you know the kind
of relationship with your mom where you
can talk to her transparently i would
say something to her like mom you know i
love you and i have your back and i
respect you and i want you to be happy
and so
i support what you're doing but i just
want you to know it's hard for me
and i'm not ready yet
i'm i can't leap through the roof and
excitement over it and and i just want
you to know if it ever seems as if
i don't have your back please understand
i just need more time and so maybe i
can't be at all the things maybe i'm not
ready to go to the movies with you guys
just yet but just give me time and
please respect my pace as i respect
yours do whatever you got to do mom to
live your best life and just give me a
little time to process and i think she'd
understand that i love that man like
just having an open conversation with
your mom about it like that's that's a
great that that's that's a great idea i
mean
again uh we were talking about at the
beginning in the podcast like when you
can have difficult conversations with
someone in a mature way yeah um that's
that's huge so yeah that's i love that
um
what you're talking about tk is clinging
clinging to uh these judgments clinging
to you know his his uh his dad's parking
spot and i wanted to say something about
that to autumn as well like when we
cling
we are preventing ourselves from moving
forward
we are when we cling we're getting
dragged by something
and um yeah i i think you know what that
means for for um
uh oh mike yeah for mike here is
like
if you want to move forward when you get
these emotions that you're clinging to
like really observe that
and really ask yourself is this the
emotion
that you want to foster is this the
emotion that you want to like just stir
up inside of you or can you look at that
and be like okay you know thank you for
this for this memory of my father i you
know this feeling is a symptom of how
much i miss my father i do miss my
father and then tried to find a way to
move forward because clinging again it's
just it's going to it's going to drag
you i can tell you that if i died
tomorrow i would hope that my wife was
able to move on within a time frame that
was suitable for her i'll never get
another business partner
[Laughter]
all right before we get on to our other
segments here alabama what do you got
for us here's a minimalist insight from
one of our listeners
hello this is megan i am 27 from tempe
arizona
and i just had a comment
so i just got out of out of a divorce
and had to move into
a one-bedroom apartment
i previously lived in a three-bedroom
house
with lots and lots of stuff and when i
moved i decided i would only take the
essentials with me
and so now i'm in a very empty apartment
i don't even have a couch i've been
sitting on the living room floor
um
but my comment was i have made a list of
the things that i want to buy
for the apartment and i am waiting two
weeks
for any item that has been added to the
list and the lists are
everything has a date on it from when
it's added so that i know that i'm
waiting enough time
to see if it's something that i actually
need
or if it's something that i can go
without
all right joe before we get to our added
value segment this week real quick for
right here right now here's one thing
that's going on in the life of the
minimalists we're doing a local event in
los angeles it's already sold out so you
can't you can't come i'm sorry
but what you can do i'm going to tell
you what you're going to miss yeah
you know you talk about the fear of
missing out
well i hope you're afraid
we're doing this to help people
get used to the fear of missing out
that's right so we're doing these small
events in los angeles only 200 people we
announced it on the podcast and it
filled up within an hour i'd say sold
out but we had free tickets and we had
pay for tickets it was pay whatever you
want and so it's accessible to anyone
right it's called sunday symposium
people from all different beliefs we're
doing it sundays at noon the first one
is august 28th and we're gonna do one a
month after that for the rest of the
year we're just trying this out we're
gonna learn a whole lot from these
experiences but you can get on the
waiting list right now
sunday symposium.com if you're on that
waiting list two things will happen one
is if a ticket frees up someone can't
make it they'll give up their ticket you
can then attend this first event or
you'll be the first to hear about future
events so you can get free tickets or
you can pay for tickets if you'd like to
help us pay for the venue
why are we doing this tk
we're doing this because
we love to play
we love to discover
we love to be curious and we love to
disrupt things for the sake of
exploring something new
and i think in this whole podcasting
space it's really easy to just kind of
get comfortable in your your studios
whether you're at home or in an office
space and just kind of talk at people
and then post something up online but
there's something to be said about
getting out there and engaging real
human beings live interacting with
people creating relationships and so on
and i just think there's a powerful
dynamic that comes from that and we got
a chance to experience that when we're
on tour together there's just an energy
in the room when we're there together
with people laughing together joking
together philosophizing together
questioning and wrestling with questions
together there's no substitute for that
and given what this world experienced in
2020
i think we all have a renewed sense of
appreciation for the ability to be able
to go out and
connect um yeah
connection and community like that's
what i'm really looking forward to with
this there's a depth here that you don't
experience the podcast reaches hundreds
of thousands or some podcasts even
millions of people right but here we're
talking about 200 people it's not about
width ryan and i have talked to live
events in front of 15 000 people we've
had our own live events with several
thousand people who attend this isn't
about that it's not about going wide and
reaching the broadest possible audience
it's about what can we discover
if we go deep we have a special guest at
the first one amanda montel will be
there she'll be there just to make sure
we're not starting a cult
she wrote the book cultish and uh we
have a special musical guest there as
well we're going to play around with
these we're going to learn a lot and
you're welcome to learn with us together
we'll do audience q a we'll have a
discussion we'll have special guests
we'll have live music and so much more
sunday symposium.com
you can find all the details over there
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes as well for added value this week
here's a beautiful song from a beautiful
album by aaron wheats so aaron is a
friend with one of our friends austin st
john he does the color correction on the
podcast total video visual genius
and uh i'm grateful that we've been able
to work with him on the color and some
of the lighting for the podcast and he's
just a great guy who works over at
mosaic and someone he works with and is
friends with aaron weetz has a beautiful
album nick drake put out an album 50
years ago called pink moon and he's sort
of the progenitor to today's modern
singer-songwriter
music
and
this album is a reinterpretation of that
it's
all
made with a
modular synth and i thought it was
beautiful to play this on our first
episode with tk coleman because
what
what has worked really well for 50 years
or for a long time for
nick drake
now he's reinterpreted that and that's
what we're doing with this podcast it's
worked really well for a long time with
me and ryan and guests but bringing tk
on so we can have these discussions so
we can disagree in a way that is helpful
that is meaningful that is useful to the
audience is really important so i hope
you enjoy this track from aaron wheats
this is the title track to pink moon by
the way if you're watching the video
version of the podcast you can just
click somewhere up here there will be
the youtube version of the song by the
way we got two more hours of less on
actually it's three more hours on the
minimalist private podcast this week we
went a while it is the best five dollars
you'll ever spend or 10 bucks if you
want the the video version of the
podcast with five bucks for the audio
version the podcast you get access to
all of our archives as well just visit
the minimalist.com slash private or
click the link in the description to
subscribe and get your personal link so
that our weekly maximal episode plays in
your favorite podcast app you'll also
gain immediate access to recordings of
live events
weekly home tours we're doing this new
segment where we go into our homes
weekly and you'll get to check that out
and our private community of thousands
of open-minded minimizers like you in
fact here's a thoughtful testimonial
from one of our lovely private podcast
subscribers alabama you read dl's
comment
i have followed you guys since your
couch surfing days and you have always
added value to my life but your recent
maximal episode about political clutter
that was the best conversations ever
your private podcast has expanded my
world in all the ways i've been craving
but wasn't finding it has answered
questions i didn't even know how to ask
and it's the first podcast i want to
re-listen to it is so
packed with wisdom discomfort and
mind-expanding ideas
thank you for all the years and
especially for this conversation that
was one of my favorite conversations tk
was actually part of that as well yeah
the political clutter episode and ryan
and i did another one recently called
how to be satisfied i think those two
which are recorded relatively recently
are two of my favorite episodes we've
ever done and so i think just signing up
for a month check it out for one month
five bucks you can just check those two
conversations out well worth your time
but also the conversation we just had
for episode 351 three plus hours
of living with less you can follow the
minimalists on tiktok instagram facebook
and twitter at the minimalist if you
have a question comment or a tip for our
podcast give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at theminimalists.com if you
want our podcast show notes in your
inbox sign up for our email list over at
theminimalists.com on behalf of ryan
nicodemus tk coleman alabama podcast
sean jordan no more professor sean
social jess danny unknown
post-production peter emma the immigrant
and the rest of our team my name is
joshua fields milburn if you leave here
today with just one message
let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
peace
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it